fed raises rates by half a percentage
point
the biggest hike in two decades to fight
inflation so cnbc story page three
okay
so the federal reserve one was they
raised it's a benchmark interest rate a
half a percentage point the most
aggressive step yet to fight against 40
or high inflation inflation is much too
high and we understand the hardship is
it it is causing we're moving
expeditiously to bring it back down the
federal chairman powell said the
american people he noted the burden of
inflation on lower income people saying
we're strongly committed to restoring
price stability okay by increasing by 50
basis power along with the move to
higher end rates the central bank
indicator will begin reducing asset
holding on this nine trillion dollar
balance sheet the fed has been buying
bonds to keep interest rates low and
money flowing okay so what does this
mean here's what it means
what happens rates go up to five percent
can you go to mortgage calculator just
go mortgage calculator okay whatever you
got somewhere there uh all right so
when a person buys a house they buy a
house based on what loan amount interest
rate or payment on a monthly basis
people buy a house on payment right they
say i can't afford three grand a month
that's how the decisions made okay
all right so at go to six go to seven
hundred thousand dollars no go to 700
yeah keep going up keep going up make
the payment three thousand dollars okay
at three percent
and my budget is three grand a month i
can get a seven hundred and twenty seven
thousand dollar loan
okay because my payment is three grand a
month
interest rates next year gonna go six
plus so go to six percent just change
that that's all you need to change
put six there right boom
now it went to four thousand thirty six
but let's bring it back to three
thousand dollars
so three thousand dollars the only loan
i can now afford is what
539 it dropped two hundred thousand
dollars
so somebody may say well pat what does
this really mean it means two things
home prices are about to drop 10 to 30
percent okay
and people buying homes mortgage and
real estate industry is gonna get hit
very very hard okay it's natural this is
gonna happen
and
folks are gonna sit there saying what
the hell do i do because i can still
only afford what three thousand dollars
a month
rent control ain't gonna change rent's
gonna go stay the same if not even go
higher
because when [ __ ] like this hits the fan
guess what uh renters do they say well
listen you can't afford to buy buy a
house anyways so you got to pay 10 more
rent right so rather than your rent
being three thousand dollars a month is
3 300 a month inflation comes back and
hurts the people that we wanted to
protect
initially so we make a decision that
sounds good and we're heroes today but
we hurt them two three four five years
down the line and we're feeling it today
and by the way as ugly as it is today
this is going to get very ugly in 2023
and 2024. it's going to get hit very
ridiculously very hard it's coming 128
months of economic expansion so what are
your thoughts on this
well i mean i'm no financial expert you
know as soon as
my whole life i've never i've kind of
been allergic to money and i don't know
if i inherit that from my father he was
a lawyer but never build his clients you
know we grew up pretty poor and
everyone's like you're rich your dad's a
lawyer it's like yeah why do people keep
saying that you know i mean come to find
out he just was an altruist and you know
it was terrible with money didn't build
his client
um
so you know but as somebody who now has
to make money and has to pay a mortgage
i've seen these ebbs and tides you know
fluctuate all the time it it's it's
harder some years it's easier other
years i think it's got to balance out um
actually interestingly enough and not
just because i was playing him in parity
at the time
when romney was against obama and the
the financial uh situation i just
watched the big short again on the plane
ride down sick
yeah adam mckay's
same movie
second to none um
i was thinking you know romney was
probably going to be the better choice
because then the banks are kind of going
to chill out and loosen up and the money
can start coming in simply because a lot
of this a lot i think a lot of the
financial
fluctuations have to do with
who's in office who's who's
who's looking out for who again the
lobbyists and you know who's who's
helping each other at the highest level
now
i've also been warned that the fed's
going to raise interest rates for a long
time it's been a long time since they
had i don't see this as something that's
insane if it goes up and up and up and
up yeah we're going to have a pro you
know a bigger problem but i don't think
it's going to really
i don't know what difference it's going
to make at this point you know what i
mean in a negative way
it's got to get better inflation has to
come down
oh no no don't get a twist you don't
think that the interest rate hike will
bring inflation down no it it will i
think it will here's why i say i think
because
i also thought
that
uncertainty
would have taken gold to 5000 and gold
never moved
okay so there's a lot of triggers that
historically
if i press this
this goes up right if i press this this
closes a lot of those things that
historically have worked together it was
completely out to question during covet
like wait a minute what gold is supposed
to go up gold state flat bitcoin went
here
you know rates like hey so i don't know
what's gonna happen but i will tell you
he has to do it he can't keep the race
that down i don't even know why they've
kept the race that down for that long
that's the question right i don't know
if they've kept it that down for that
long
but at the end of the day the only
reason he has to do it is because
there's inflation the only reason we
have inflation is because we print away
too much money the only reason we print
away too much money is because we listen
to everybody complaining way too much
the only reason we listen to people
complain too much is because we try to
please the people to win votes and win
elections
and then boom this is a ripple effect so
everything is a ripple effect and back
again and back again so
uh unfortunately that's the way we have
our election process our election
process is by people getting up there
and putting the fear in voters to win
their votes whoever's able to persuade
the best and you can even use the word
manipulate to get people to realize and
create a massive enemy hey then we're
going to go to xyz for you but then the
same people that voted for that policy
end up getting shafted that's just how
this thing works and we have to get a
little bit more deeper
to
you know like hey you know
i want to buy some roblox dad okay you
want to buy roblox yeah go bring your
money i'm paying for it yeah okay i'll
buy all of it
all right spend all the money on roblox
all right that i want to buy this go use
your money i ran out of money okay i
don't have it
right but dad i didn't tell you about
roblox you chose to roblox you were
happy for two weeks when you bought all
the roadblocks how come you're not happy
now there is consequences man and we're
not talking about consequences
fortunately financial literacy is now
becoming more and more required in
certain school systems my daughter goes
we go
very nice public school system uh by
design
and i'm going to take it with her this
summer she's got to take a financial
literacy awesome so i'm gonna take it
with her sick yeah just to get into i
love that um but you're right i mean you
know a lot of it is cultural we the this
generation you know they call it the
helicopter parenting or
you know uh
i like to say when everyone's special no
one will be you know the participation
trophy generation and it it it you hit
on a point there with uh talking about
your kids asking for stuff we gotta
learn as a people
that
because we're in a capitalist system
whatever the whatever the policies are
going to be
it starts at home
financial responsibility starts at home
and
i think there's a lot out there where it
it
finances are
are the product of something
beyond me
right
and that's got to probably change
as a cultural as a culture where yeah
with the saddle yeah you know i'm
processing all this i'm listening yeah
you're the money guy i mean i i think
well ultimately it comes down to doing
the hard things
and having the tough conversations and
looking deeper down the surface like we
like
these types of things are
essential to understand if you're going
to be
living in a capitalist society living in
america but back to our initial point
it's much easier just to watch the amber
heard johnny depp story and just kind of
yeah what's going on with that well sure
in your spare time but work is different
now than it ever was yeah but you know
work it's not it's not what you're gonna
say no it used to be you go to work you
get a salary you know your salary was
you knew what your annual budget was all
that stuff that's off the table for the
most part today it's entrepreneurship is
more and more important the whole nature
of a side hustle as a positive is weird
to me you know what i mean that you need
two jobs you want a second job if you're
trying to get ahead financially because
your first job doesn't pay you enough
now it's almost essential that both
couples work you know both members of
the both parents have to work one
probably has two jobs that's weird
that's so what's that what's that from
those so then so years and years and
years of
maybe financial disparity between the
what the rich and the poor so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]